what's going on everybody welcome to
part three of the key V tutorial series
in this video what we're talking about
is how we can change the screen the view
the page whatever the heck you want to
call it we're calling them screens and
key V so with that let's get into it so
the first thing we need to do is import
the screen manager so from key v UI X
screen manager
we want to import screen manager we also
want to import screen because we're
going to be using that as well so now
coming on down here rather than epic app
just simply returning connect page we
what we want to do is be able to switch
screens between between pages so in
theory you could go from page to page to
page in a very linear manner but chances
are that's not really what you want to
do so instead really what you want to be
able to do is manage your screens with
the screen manager so so what we're
gonna do here is under the in this build
method we're not gonna return connect
page anymore instead we're gonna build
this like screen manager thing so first
of all self dot self dot screen
underscore manager is gonna be a screen
manager object and then what we want to
do is add our you know pages or our
screens to the screen managers so what
we're gonna say is self dot Connect page
is gonna be a connect page object and
then what we're going to say is screen
equals screen and we're gonna give this
screens name connect so now anytime we
want to reference this screen we're just
going to reference connect the string so
then we're going to say screen dot add
underscore widget and then self dot
connect page and then finally we're
gonna self dot screen manager dot add
widgets that screen cool so this is what
you're gonna do every time you want to
add a screen that you want to be able to
reference by the string so now we're
gonna do is the same thing but we want
some sort of next pay
I'm gonna call this the info page so
self dot info page is equal to an info
page object which doesn't yet exist but
we will create one then we're gonna say
screen equals screen and in this case
the name will be info screen dot add
widgets self dot connect page info page
and then self dot screen manager dot add
widgets screen cool so now we've got our
two pages so you should be able to
notice the pattern here between these
two things pretty simple so now we can
add you know an infinite number of pages
we can call upon those pages when
someone say like clicks a button or
something like that so you could have
some sort of nav bar and your app it can
definitely be pretty darn awesome now
for us we don't even have an info page
yet so if I should do that also rather
remember before we returned we have to
return something right we return the
thing that we want the app to run right
because this is the build method so in
this case we actually are gonna return
self dot screen manager cool alrighty so
now what we need to do is like our
connect page we need to create an info
page so coming down here I'm just gonna
throw it right here I'm gonna call this
class info page it is like the other oh
pretty sure it's a capital yeah it's
going to inherit from grid layout also
in the init method same thing as before
so self kwargs
and then we're basically just gonna run
so it's this here right so actually I'm
just gonna copy come down here not too
far pasta and rather than self that
calls us to I'm actually gonna say it's
one column now and now we're gonna do is
self dot message and this is like a
dynamic message it's not a message what
we're just gonna set and apparently I
guess if you use the key V style thing
or the key V Docs I don't know what
you're supposed to call these things but
they're dot K V files they're kind of
like CSS
for HTML or something like that no real
intention to cover it here I did cover
in the older series I just I just hate
splitting it out like that I'm assuming
if you have like a huge enough app it
would become really useful to have it
like split away like logic in one area
and design in another but I just I just
don't like it but just understand that
does exist so check that out it's just
the dot kV or kV Files I forget where
we're supposed to call them but anyway
if you use that apparently this little
thing doesn't happen but anyway well let
me type it out first and then we'll talk
about it so the message will be a label
object and the horizontal align is going
to be Center and then we also want to do
the same thing with vertical line which
in this case is actually middle imagine
a world where we just use the same
terminology for for the same thing
anyway what size 34:39
doesn't really matter anyway that's our
message right it's a label but it
doesn't currently have anything we need
to be able to update this label as
needed so we're gonna first say you know
trying to connect but then maybe if
there's an error or something we want to
update it with whatever the error is and
so on so what we need to do is bind a
method to it so we're gonna say self dot
message bind and we're gonna say width
is equal to self dot update update
update text width and then we're gonna
say self dot add widget' self dot
message then what we're gonna say is in
a new method well we need two things we
need to update text width and then we
need the actual message itself so the
issue is if you just hat so you have a
label and then you're gonna add stuff to
that label that in theory could change
the size of things and all that and so
you have to just keep updating it like I
said if you have the Cavey style files
or whatever apparently that doesn't
happen like you don't actually have to
like
resize it yourself or like listen for
the resize so it's probably just because
things are called in a different order
when you're using those files I really
don't know anyway define updates
underscore info and this will be self
message we're gonna update the message
for this label so we're gonna say self
dot message dot text equals that message
so that should just update it for us and
then finally we need to do the update
text width so we're going to say define
update text width and that's self and
then anything else but we just don't
care and in this case we're just going
to say self dot message dot text
underscore size equals self dot message
dot width times zero point nine and then
we're not worried about the Y so now
that should be good message with yes so
we just want that to take up ninety
percent basically of this page like it's
just like anything if it goes all the
way to the edges it just looks kind of
goofy okay cool so we've got our two
pages we've got them connected to the
screen manager okay now what all we need
to do is figure out how do we like what
do we want to have call these changes
right so you might have a nav bar or
something but in this case it's just
when the user hits join right so when
they hit join we want to change the page
or change the screen to this info page
that says hey we're connecting or we got
an error whatever okay so in this case
that's what we want to do so what we
want to do now is go to our join button
which is in our connect page and cool so
what we want to happen when someone
clicks that join button is first of all
we're going to take this print statement
I'm just gonna get rid of it but I'm
gonna first copy what was inside of it
and I'm going to say info equals that
bit of information then we're going to
say
well first what we have to do is so we
we want to be able to reference the
instance that is running right now so in
order for us to do that we're gonna say
chat app equals epic app and then we're
going to say chat app dot run but now we
can reference things with chat app so
we're gonna come back up to the join
button and we're going to say chat app
dot info page dot update info with our
info and then and so like that'll go to
our info page where is info page updates
the info that's the message text to
whatever that message is that we passed
which is the info but a boom bada bing
we get over to this label which just so
happens to also be listening for the
resize after we've updated it to set to
90% of the width crazy
okay so we've updated that page that
info is updated we just can't see that
screen yet so what we need to do is
bring that screen to the forefront so
what we're gonna do is a chat app dot
screen manager dot current equals boom
info that's it so anytime you have some
sort of thing right in this case our
button so when someone on presses that
join button that we created it runs this
method and if all you wanted to do was
change the page boom this is the only
line that you would need to run but I'm
sorry this is the only line that you
need to run but we wanted to update that
info whatever info was on that info page
so we ran this first and did some other
stuff save some other stuff but
basically to change the screen one line
of code right there cool so honestly
that should be everything we need up to
this point change the screen so let's
test it out let's run it ok here we go
it's not gonna be able to connect but at
least tell us cool so it says attempting
to join
that server or that IP that port as
username cool and it changed the screen
awesome very good very good okay so now
what we want to do is connect all this
to our actual socket code and start
building that page now the way that
we're gonna do that
if you go to the text-based version of
this tutorial I'll post probably in both
versions this version and the next
version the socket server dot PI and
then the client socket or basically
socket client dot PI files I'm not gonna
go over those at all I feel like like
there's nothing new in there the server
is the server code is exactly what we
did in the sockets tutorial and then the
client dot PI code is like just slightly
modified so there's really nothing new
there if you want to learn about that
stuff at the end of this video I
strongly suggest go to the socket series
it's all already released so you can go
through those if you want to learn more
about those otherwise I guess just stay
tuned to the next tutorials quick quick
shout out to my recent channel members
Matej and vis Aranda kumara thank you
guys very much for your support you guys
are incredible in the next video we're
gonna be talking about scheduling tasks
so setting up things like functions and
methods and stuff like that to run on
some sort of schedule using the kiwi
clock otherwise that's it for now
questions comments concerns love notes
whatever go over to them below otherwise
I'm gonna see you guys in the next video